cinéma avec la sortie demain du vélo de
ghislain lambert du vélo de ghislain
lambert plutôt vos le portrait d'un
anonyme du peloton avec un benoît
poelvoorde qui rêve du maillot jaune
pascal deschamps alain poirier marie
pierre cassignard même s'il est née le
même jour que lui
ghislain lambert le sait bien il ne sera
jamais eddy merckx le film raconte son
destin le destin de galio comme disent
les italiens
un homme du peloton au service du leader
mais qui jamais ne cessent de rêver
d'une impossible gloire le film déroule
20 ans d'une vie dix ans d'une carrière
tout y passe les amours les galères et
les petits trucs qui font aller plus
loin plus vite
comment ça moi j'ai tout mis il répond
de là dedans
[Applaudissements]
guerbert de fages a toujours existé
depuis la création de recettes des
épreuves
quand on voit les reportages d'albert
londres sur le tour de france je pleure
quelle année quand il quand une
interview les pellissier ils leur
demandent à quoi ils marchent et des
autres montre à tous les produits la
cocaïne comédie tour à tour burlesque
qui est mouvante le film est bourré de
clins d'oeil je retiens senti le casque
de josé garcia
c'est une histoire vraie ces reliques à
quoi que ça peut-être de cuir on l'avait
baptisé tête devait s'appeler robic et
qui avait demandé pour tester son casque
pour lui frappe sur la tête avec un
marteau très fort et ça donne résultat
qu'on va dire le film ok pour
l'avant-première des coureurs des vrais
avons été conviés l' approche
respectueuse verbist du film ne les ont
pas laissés indifférents
ils ont dû vraiment être avec des gens
bien bien dans le milieu cycliste pour
pour leur donner tout saisi des mêmes
les répliques et où c'était vraiment
quelque chose passionnel on se met dans
la roue de jean lambert sans effort et
on laisse le nih ont fait la route avec
lui on se dit que jamais plus on ne
suivra le tour comme avant
[Musique]